Luffy law and kit combined forces to
take down the Monstrous Emperor's big
mom and kaido but each of them is
actually quite incredibly different law
is a master tactician kit is a
mechanical genius and Luffy brings
Freedom everywhere he goes so instead of
these three fighting against each other
and competing for most of the story I
wonder exactly how well they would have
actually been able to work together on
the same crew and since we're putting
these three together let's actually
explore the really wild crew dynamics of
the entire worst generation if they were
all together in the same crew and of
course it's nearly impossible for all of
these random characters to just randomly
meet up at the start of the pirate
Adventure so instead we're simply going
to put them all together on one ship as
they fly down reverse mountain and they
suddenly have to figure out how to be a
crew which of course means that the
first thing that this wildly competitive
group must now figure out is who is
going to be the captain and uh how are
they going to do that well they could
play some sort of game I guess like a
DAV back fight or a treasure hunt but I
honestly really think that they would
just settle for a straightup fight to
see who is the strongest so let's
imagine that they draw a massive Circle
and the last one standing inside the
ring gets to be captain and now you
might think that Luffy or even Captain
kid with his magnetic devil fruit powers
are the favorites to win this fight but
man are you going to be shocked by the
outcome of this insane initial class
because right at the start Trafalga law
uses his op OPI to instantly teleport
Luffy and kid outside of the Ring bam
two out already not as simple as you
thought right because remember if we're
imagining all of the worst generation at
the start of the grand line then Luffy
definitely wouldn't have access to any
of his major powerups quite yet and on
top of that none of them really know
what each other's devil fruits can
actually do and so with Luffy and kid
grumbling on the sidelines the rest of
the crew back batted out for the right
to be Captain Zoro and Killa clash with
their blades hawen uses his strawman
powers and cabone beige enters his big
father mode as they team up against The
Mad Monk or Ro then across the
battlefield the H manipulating jewelry
Bonnie is having a tough time against
the dinosaur man ex strike as the music
man aoo attacks with his explosive music
devil fruit as well and at this point
you might have realized that uh we have
technically left out one member of the
worst generation here and that is of
course Blackbeard who yes of course
we're leaving out here I mean did you
think we're going to include another
yonko into this already insanely busted
crew Also let's be real here even if we
threw Blackbeard in here he would never
get along with most of the people on
this crew and might really just end up
killing everyone in their sleep so with
no teach here who do you think would
come out on top here well I think
because it's the very first time that
they're all together here and don't know
anything about each other it's
incredibly difficult for anyone to
actually overcome Law's completely
broken ability I mean he can basically
teleport people cut them in half or
simply swap personalities which all just
seems like too much for anyone to figure
out right in the middle of this super
heated battle and so I personally think
that law would win this type of Battle
Royale and thanks to aru's ability to
tank pain and turn it into Power The Mad
Monk ends up in second and with the role
of Vice Captain for now but this won't
be the last time of course that they
battle it out because I think this crew
would adapt a system similar to kaido's
crew where the entire crew can challenge
the other crew members to move up the
ranks and so keep watching to find out
how long Luffy and kit are actually at
the complete bottom of the ranking here
but honestly though it's probably the
best possible outcome for law to be
Captain right now because he is the most
careful and tactical out of anyone of
the worst generation which means that he
should be able to at least get them to
properly sail the ship to make it to the
first island of the grand line because I
mean can they even call themselves a
crew if they can't even do that oh wait
actually hold on I just remember law
actually uses a submarine so maybe he
doesn't even know how to sail himself
well let's forget about that part for
now I guess because there are way more
important things to discuss at the
moment because the most important part
of any crew of course is the actual
roles that the crew takes and we already
said that law is a captain which is
unfortunate cuz he can't be do and arou
is Vice Captain but here are the other
roles I think work best for each of the
other crew members and while you're free
to argue against any of these or maybe
even most of these I base them mostly on
the hobbies and interests that the
author has told us about all of these
characters for example Bonnie and killer
would both open restaurants if they
weren't Pirates which means that they
should at least know how to cook
somewhat plus xri really enjoys studying
the Stars which would make him a pretty
decent Navigator in my opinion and Zaron
killer would of course be swordsman I
guess and so with all of that more or
less settled they're off on their pirate
Adventure but will this wild and
insanely powerful crew be actually able
to succeed and find the one piece we'll
see but for now there is no real way of
knowing which of the seven paths from
reverse Mountain that this crew would
actually take of course they could take
the same one that Luffy took and visit
drum Island Alabaster GA and others or
they could just take a completely
different path that we just don't really
know anything about the one thing that
is going to happen no matter what is of
course the war at Marine Fort because
this single event completely broke the
peaceful balance of the world well
peaceful but you get what I'm saying and
once Luffy hears that his brother Ace
has been captured he will of course
absolutely demand that the crew go and
save his brother and can you even
imagine the split that it would cause in
This Crew I mean on the one hand
characters like kit and urou would
probably love to go and fight in this
massive war against super strong
characters and on the other hand more
careful characters like Hawkins and
Capone and law would probably want to
stay far away in fact I think there's no
doubt that law who is still captain at
this point would flat out say no which
would once again lead to a massive brawl
because there is no way that Luffy is
letting his brother get executed without
putting up a fight although I do suppose
that Luffy could just leave the crew but
since the point is to keep them all
together here let's do imagine that
Luffy w challenges law for the right to
be captain and at this point I bet that
law would probably be sick and tired of
being captain of these stubborn Pirates
anyway so he might just step down
anyways but even if he does fight Luffy
has grown much much stronger in the
first half of the grand line and so
combined with everyone's now way better
understanding of Law's devil fruit
ability Luffy would probably be able to
overcome the surgeon and everyone else
in a second Battle Royale to become the
new captain which means that we now have
our second official worst generation
crew R so make sure to subscribe to the
channel for official worst generation
merch coming soon I'm just kidding but
seriously subscribe to the channel for
more interesting what ifs like this but
now here are the updated crew roles like
the only major changes so far being that
Luffy is a captain kit is Vice Captain
while law is now just the regular doctor
and arou has some other role on the crew
like ship ride I guess could fit pretty
well or something else although now that
I'm thinking about it I'm not sure kid
would ever want to be Vice Captain so
maybe he just stays a chore boy or
simple fighter and Zoro can be the Vice
Captain instead you decide and of course
similar like with the straw hats with
Luffy now being the captain things are
of course about to get really wild
because there is no stopping this group
from charging straight into Marine Ford
and causing massive chaos because even
though none of these characters here
have of course even reached close to
their full potential yet they are still
all incredibly strong in fact I'd put
all of them at least above the lower
tier of Warlords like Moria which yeah
isn't the strongest arguably but having
11 of them on the battlefield fighting
against the Marines could be enough to
completely change the result of the war
and one thing I think that wouldn't
change is actually Luffy teaming up with
Whitebeard and with way more strong
Fighters the Marines would have so much
more to deal with here this could mean
that the Admirals get distracted and
actually need to fight way more people
or maybe Luffy's grandfather has to jump
into the battle to help out as well plus
some of the devil fruits that the worst
generation crew bring to the battle are
just stupidly overpowered for this
specific situation for example kid's
magnetic powers could basically take all
of the swords and guns away from all the
Marine soldiers Zoro would also love the
chance to fight the world's strongest
swordsman mihawk again and ao's musical
blast would be deadly in this large
scale battle as well it's basically a
crowd control Power if you want to think
about it that way but probably the most
important ability is lost teleportation
techniques which could easily move Ace
and Luffy to safety when this magma
crazy Admiral tries to kill both of them
which means that Ace lives I know I know
a very unusual circumstance for any of
my usual what if videos but it's not all
positive because I do think that since
Whitebeard was already going all out
that he would probably still die during
this battle maybe due to ainu maybe due
to his heart attack who knows which
means that Blackbeard could still take
his devil fuit and go on to become an
emperor but now with asave the worst
generation crew Retreats along with the
rest of the Whitebeard Pirates Alliance
and so wow I mean this outcome is just
going to completely change the story a
lot because with Asa life he would very
likely go off with the rest of the
Whitebeard Pirates and who knows they
might not really want to avenge their
fallen captain and instead might
continue as a major force in the new
world instead of being completely wiped
out by blackbeards but maybe the thing
that we do have to discuss the most is
of course the time skip now if you
remember this was originally when Luffy
learned the basics of hockey now I don't
think that Luffy would be able to spend
two years training and be able to keep
this wild crew together so maybe Marco
from whitebeard's crew gives Luffy and
the others a crash course in hockey as a
thanks for saving Ace maybe Ace does it
himself or maybe Luffy's original
teacher Ry would still show up and teach
him and maybe the rest of the crew so
basically they all learn hockey and are
all ready to head into the new world
worlds way earlier however this is where
things could all fall apart completely
because now there are a few very
important points to consider here first
Luffy has probably awakened his
conqueror hockey by now meaning he's
truly a candidate to be pirate king
second this was also the part of the
story that many of the worst generation
gave up on becoming pirate king for
example many of them joined either the
emperor big mom or kaido's crew or just
straight up gave up on their dream and
finding the one piece alt together and
so all of that means that many of the
worst generation might actually be fine
truly accepting Luffy as that captain
now since he's on the path to becoming
an Emperor as well with them however kit
is the one exception here because he's
basically the only one besides Luffy in
the actual story who's still fighting to
become pirate king right now but for now
let's imagine he doesn't quite leave at
least yet which does mean that we have
to ask what do they do next from here
well the crew could still very easily
follow the path to dress Rosa to achieve
law big dream of killing do Flamingo and
that could once again lead them to this
giant elephant where the crew would once
again learn about the road poneglyphs
which are these red stones that
basically have directions to love tail
and the one piece which means that it
now makes a ton of sense for this crew
to split up and go after the road
poneglyphs owned by the emperor kaido
and big mom so half the crew goes to hul
Kake islands and the other half goes to
wano and honestly though right now at
this point it would probably go pretty
poorly for either of these groups if
they triy to go for a straight up fight
I mean I can just imagine Bonnie's food
cravings going absolutely wild in Hulk
Island and exposing the cre as soon as
they set foot on the island and in wano
there is definitely no one who can take
down kaido at this point yet but let's
imagine that they somehow actually manag
to slip in steal the poneglyphs on Hulk
Island even without the true MVP Brooke
I mean they have strong Fighters than
the normal group who went to Hulk island
in the first place plus Capone beige
might make a pretty good plan so
certainly possible to survive as long as
they don't don't get caught by big mom
herself which now leads everyone back to
wano where the rate on kaido's Castle
could mostly take place like normal I'm
actually pretty sure that on average
this group is quite a lot stronger than
the regular Straw Hat crew so who knows
the fight against the king of the Beast
could even be a lot easier here which
all means that the worst generation crew
is so close to finding the one piece and
are ready to take on the remaining
Empress but hold on surely it won't be
that easy not with this type of crew
right because while I'm sure that they
would have bonded a lot over the course
of their adventures and some of them
might even be close friends like Luffy
and Bonnie I could just imagine
something going horribly wrong with this
collection of people like for example
this might be the perfect opportunity
for kids to actually backstab Luffy and
take the poneglyphs copies or something
similar like that and if that were to
happen it is probably because this crew
wouldn't have nearly the level of
loyalty that the other straw heads like
Uso Nami and ch half towards Luffy I
mean Luffy literally had to save each of
the weakling Trio's home Islands but
actually wonder if they would still have
needed saving if they had eaten an
overpowered devil fruit like let's say
Luffy's NAA fruit and if you want to see
just how unbelievably incredible sun god
Nami or Joy boy usub story would get you
can watch that video right here for now
thanks for watching and I will see you
hopefully in the next one